[Music]
so it seems almost cheap
to play this video for a daily
cancellation because these are these
things are a dime a dozen but the fact
that they're a dime a dozen
is precisely the point i'm not sure when
this was originally filmed seems to be
recent but it went viral yesterday this
is conservative commentator
caitlin bennett doing one of those
trusty always fruitful dumb guy on the
street interviews
again you've seen these a million times
and that's the problem
but this one is perhaps even worse than
you might expect
just listen what year did america
declare its independence
girl july 1st 1989
what year did christopher columbus
discover the americans love christopher
don't know
i mean i'm done christopher was it 1976
how many years make up a century isn't
that a thousand
what year was george w bush elected
president
the 1800s i'm assuming
i don't know who was the last president
of the 1990s
1990s oh uh
i actually no idea nixon what year was
barack obama elected president
i don't even know what century are we
currently living in
let's just go 50th i don't
america was discovered in 1976 and
declared independence on july 1
1989. seems like a pretty quick timeline
but then again we are living in the 50th
century so all that stuff happened while
like 3000 years ago
um this is needless to say some
extremely dumb stuff you have to try to
be this dumb
it must be exhausting to be so
overwhelmingly moronic on a daily basis
every hour of the day can you imagine if
i had to carry this level of stupidity
around with me all the time
i'd collapse and have a heart attack the
coroner would say yep looks like he had
a fatal case of the dumbs
third one this week it's an epidemic now
all of the uh the necessary qualifiers
must be added that these were the
dumbest of the dumb
who made it into the clip presumably
plenty of people answered the question
easily and were summarily cut from the
final edit
but even so it is way too easy to go out
and get content like this
uh we know that these kinds of videos
are the tip of the idiot iceberg
there's been a great many surveys and
polls with larger sample sizes that have
come to similar conclusions
think of that c-span poll a few years
ago that found half of americans
can't name one sitting supreme court
justice
there was a survey in 2019 that found 20
percent of americans
can't correctly identify a single branch
of government
a poll in 2017 showed that almost 40
percent can't cite
any of the rights protected in the first
amendments
the woodrow wilson national fellowship
foundation gave a basic history exam to
41 000 american adults
a year or two ago and found that 60
percent couldn't pass it
another survey found that almost 40
percent of americans think that benjamin
franklin invented the light bulb
12 thought eisenhower was a civil war
general
a civil war general eisenhower um
i could go on and on and on the point is
that stupidity
is a national crisis i believe that it
is
and what makes it worse is that there is
no mitigating circumstance to let the
stupid people off the hook
no adult with a brain capable of basic
functioning
has any cover here none of them have an
excuse
because everyone has access to the
accumulated knowledge of all mankind
right at their fingertips everyone can
find any information they want
and accessing it as is as easy as moving
their thumbs across a screen
it's not like it was in say 1890 when
huge
swaths of the population were never
taught how to read
and their only source of information
about the outside world and current
events was maybe at best a weekly
newspaper
that a lot of them couldn't read and
then whatever scuttlebutt
you heard around town if you were within
a day's travel of any kind of town
if they wanted to know to know something
if there was information that they
didn't have that they wanted
there was obviously no search engine
which with which to find it
although i would like to interview those
same people and ask them when do you
think google was invented
i don't know 1573
but if someone back in those days you
know they couldn't use a search engine
engine if they wanted to know something
they could ask someone
or they could try to find the
information in whatever books were
accessible
and if the information wasn't there if
nobody around them knew it
and it wasn't in a book then they just
just weren't ever going to know
that thing they would have to say well i
guess i'm not going to know that
there were so many things about the
world that a person in those days
may have wanted to know but simply could
not know
because there was no way to acquire the
knowledge
compare that today to today when if i
want to know for instance
how many earths can fit in the sun 1.3
million
or how old the the oldest living
vertebrate 500 year old greenland shark
is or or whether the pain in my back is
a sign that i'm dying of a rare bone
disease yes
i could just look it up on the internet
and have the answer in the blink of an
eye
and yet with this tool with this vast
expanse of knowledge readily available
still we choose dumbness it's like a guy
in the desert collapsing and dying of
thirst
while wearing a camelback full of water
it doesn't make any it's it's
it almost doesn't make any sense so how
does this happen
how do we end up snatching imbecility
from the jaws of knowledge
well part of the blame goes to the
school system which has utterly failed
to do the one thing it is supposed to do
in which we're paying good money for it
to do
part of the blame goes to the media
which muddies the water with lies and
half truths
part of the blame goes to the internet
itself which offers knowledge but also
offers cheap and constant distraction
it gives you the choice to feed your
mind or numb it expand your horizons
or lose yourself in the fog most people
it turns out prefer the numb and the fog
because it's easy
and it keeps you from thinking about
uncomfortable things like your own
mortality
which i believe is the primary motivator
that drives our screen addiction in the
first place
is that we don't want to think about
immortality but but notice the word
choice
the one thing about modern society for
all of its flaws
is that it offers a lot of choices
more choices than anyone in history ever
had
too many choices it turns out but they
are choices all the same
whether you use the internet to make
yourself smarter and more interesting
which you can do or
dumber and duller is a choice
and that's why after partial blame has
been doled out this way and that
the rest the majority must fall on the
ignoramuses
themselves whose obliviousness and
foolishness is as much a moral failing
as an intellectual one
and that's why and you knew this was
coming back around
because it always does everyone in that
video and all the videos like it
should not be allowed to vote it is a we
make a
mockery of ourselves by allowing all of
those people to vote
that's also why and you definitely knew
this was coming
they're all canceled listen hit that
subscribe button right now
do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated